I've also very happy to be with you on
this feast today and I thought it would
be a good idea because it's the Feast of
the Assumption in the Orthodox Church we
call it the Feast of the Dormition of
the mother of God and so we'll we'll go
through that as I'm talking but because
it's such a it's such an important feast
and because also I think that especially
in North America you know it's with so
much Protestant tradition in North
America the the place of the Our Lady
the place of the mother of God of Mary
in our tradition is sometimes difficult
for people to understand and so
hopefully what all we do we do it with
you is going through the visual imagery
of how her image began to take form in
the Christian tradition and by doing
that hopefully it will also help us to
understand her role in the church and a
role in the universal story
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
and so to to begin right away when the
church started to take form
you know when the persecutions started
to subside and people had a bit of more
time - more time and more space to write
and to think and to look at the
Christian story right away people
started to identify marry with
typologically with all the places in the
Old Testament that when God manifested
himself his space in which God
manifested himself so we heard it today
for those who were there at the service
we heard Mary being called the temple
the temple of God and so the notion that
she's the temple because in her womb she
received as he received divinity in her
womb becomes the the let's say the the
basic pattern around which all of her
imagery and then all of the things we
say about her all of the ways we
interact with her are going to take form
and so she's read she's said to be the
Ark just like the Ark of the Covenant
had the glory of God which descended on
the ark with the two angels on the side
of the Ark and so you have this
invisible glory which comes and sets
itself on the mark so to the mother God
is seen as this Ark and so the first
image that we find of the mother of God
is an image that will come to be known
as the seat of wisdom or the throne of
wisdom here this is probably the most
possibly the first image it's not the
first image that we know of of Mary and
so it's very neat up because it's in the
catacombs it has a very kind of fluid
the fluid style that we find in the
catacombs and there is some dispute
they're not it's the image of Mary but I
think it's pretty obvious because if you
look at the image you can see there's
there is there's the mother of god she's
holding the child and there's someone
next to her can you see the person and
to keep see what they're doing
but he's pointing to something he's
pointing to the star which is above her
and so this is a it comes from up like
an old Old Testament prophecy about
about them about the star to the star
and the star the star that didn't know
at the Star of Bethlehem so here are
here's Mary who is under his start oh I
think that's a pretty convincing
convincing argument has to to think that
that's an image of Mary when a person
who they're married but very quickly we
get this representation of Mary where
she is sitting straight on and then on
her lap is the infant Christ and this
really refers like I said this notion of
the throne of wisdom and it's we also
when we think of throne we have to think
of seat right remember that the Ark of
the Covenant on the Ark of the Covenant
it was what it's called the mercy seat
right and then on this mercy seat came
to to set on the mercy seat the the
divine glory and so that is the role
that she now takes because she has
received in her womb the Christ and so
Christ sitting on her lap because the
becomes typologically linked to the
glory of God which descends and sets
itself on the ark so so she is also
representative art you can see that
that's there's also a reason why we have
these two angels which are next to
so these two angels which are on our
inside which also hint to this idea of
the Ark of the Covenant with the two
cherubs that that flanked the the seat
of Mercy so here again this is a this
ivory here is from the 5th century so
it's quite it's very early in the
Christian tradition this is an accosting
icon from the sixth century and here we
really get that exactly that that same
image we have the mother of God in the
center very very central and very you
know like a seat and on her is the
Christ child and above her as well you
see again he's sitting in the two angels
then our act that are flanking the this
deceit
just like the Ark of the Covenant one of
the things also to notice in these
images is how the manner in which Christ
sits on her he becomes like her center
so she becomes like a covering and then
in in the middle you have Christ which
is sitting and becomes her center so in
those images when you look at them
you'll notice that the head of Christ is
always on her heart but it's always on
her Center so you have this concentric
image of Christ in the middle you know
the divine glory and then around him
this arc this seat which surrounds the
glory of God here's here's a bit later
this is from the 10th century again in
the same structure you see mother of god
you see Christ on her lap and you see
the two angels up above okay this is
always referring to this image of the of
the Ark of the Covenant covenant and the
image this image of the throne of wisdom
became the central image of the entire
medieval period up to the Gothic top up
to the Gothic era this would have been
the image that most people would have
seen of the mother of God would have
seen if either in an icon or in a carved
image or in a statue you know here's a
very old statue of that exact same type
you know and so you can probably think
of some of these images then or not even
some of the some of the black Madonna's
have that form where it's it you know
it's the it's the mother of God and the
Christ child is a bird on her lap and
his head is usually in her center the
the important thing to understand in
terms of typology is that when we see
the Christ child when we see the baby
Jesus of course there is this there's
this whole relationship of the mother to
her child there is this this
disaffection there's all of this but
there's also something else going on
there's something about the the notion
of showing Christ as a child surrounded
by his mother that points to that the
the secret that points to the hiddenness
of Christ just like Christ is hidden in
those we encounter just like Christ
is hidden in us so to this notion of
Christ who is who is on her lap but
ultimately who is in her womb is this
this this notion of this hidden thing
that that it's hidden image of Christ
which is in it of course for her it was
it was much more than you know it was a
it takes how can I say this for her a
typical took on a cosmic aspect but
still it becomes the image of this
encounter
can have as well that that we can all
have this possibility of encountering
Christ hidden in in the people that we
meet and which is why we talked about in
iconography we talked about this image
of the Christ child as he say it's the
Christ Emanuel and so when we talk about
the Christ child who saves Christ
Emanuel and Christ Emanuel is exactly
that it is Christ in us Christ among us
it is Christ who is with us and so this
image will culminate you know into an
image which is something like this this
is a Russian image but it can help you
kind of see what it what this is about
and so in the hurt this is almost seeing
Christ hidden in the womb of Mary I mean
I it's not totally that but you have
this circle and then inside this circle
you have the the Christ child and then
she is around him like this covering you
know and so we also have to pin here
here again you can see now this is a lot
later now this is this is like I think
it's like 12th century and so once again
you can see the two angels are there so
this time you know from the sixth
century from the fifth century this
image continues to to exist and
continues also to take into account that
typology connecting the Old Testament
with the New Testament always saying you
know those things that those people saw
in the Old Testament well we have seen
the fullness of it in human form
now that Christ has has been incarnated
[Music]
and so and so another way to also
understand it is to understand it as the
embodiment of Christ that is the mother
of God not only is the ark for us but
she also becomes an image of the church
itself when she becomes an image of that
body into which Christ comes in and end
up and finds his flesh and so she is the
she is
the source of the flesh of the Christ
child she is she is not that out of
which Christ took his body and so she
becomes an image of the church itself
and so I say that you might think like
okay you're stretching and you're
stretching until that length book as we
keep going you're going to see how
obvious it becomes you know at the
beginning it might look a bit like I'm
trying to over-interpret this but you'll
see you'll see as we go and so this
image is really what's really the
central image of the mother of God for
you know maybe about six hundred seven
hundred years and then certain images
started to develop out of that image but
if we understand this notion of this
gathering in that she is the body that
gathers in and in her Center appears
this divine this divine presence and
becomes and is incarnate but then also
becomes the image by which we also can
find Christ in those around us then we
also understand that that's also what's
happening in the icon of the Nativity so
the icon of the image of the Nativity
which is the birth of Christ we see that
traditionally this has been lost to a
lot of people today but traditionally
from the year 70 you know Justin Martyr
mentioned the christ was born in a cave
and so this notion that christ was born
in a cave now helps us to see was going
to start to help us to see another
aspect of this body and right this
embodiment of christ the church as being
the creation itself right as being
creation itself which accepts which
takes in the divine and is able to
manifest it and so Christ enters into
the ground enters into the earth enters
into into this this you know that this
cave and once again you have
the secret beginning of Christ's life
think of it as a seed right a seed that
comes down and is planted in the ground
and then is going to finally appear in
his full glory but at that moment you
know there was still the secret aspect
to it you know um all right I'm going to
also feel free to ask questions
seriously because I I'm trying to kind
of talk to a lot of different people
with a lot of different backgrounds and
so if I say something that just kind of
makes you think what did he just say you
know feel free to raise your hand and
ask me to specify that's not that's not
a problem and so as as this image as the
mother of God becomes this image of the
container of the church of that by which
Christ is able to come into the world
then just like the church our role is
saying what's the role of the church
right the role of the church in a great
part is to point right to say say to
glorify to stew to pray to say here here
it is this is what we're turned towards
right we are all turned towards Christ
and and and here he is and so it points
towards Christ but that's one of the
functions of the church is to is to all
point towards Christ and so one of the
most important images of of Mary is is
this image this is called the haruka
tree on the hood again tria is at this
traditionally it is the oldest not this
particular painting but the type this
type traditionally it is the oldest icon
this is really like in the in the
tradition of the church that in the like
how can I say this in the history of the
in the historical analysis it's hard to
know because this is really a
traditional story but according to
tradition the auto gantry are the first
image of this type was
painted by Saint Luke and and what it is
it is the mother who is showing the way
and another another name for this image
is you know the lady of the way or she
who shows the way and so you can see
that once again we're square we're still
in tin at the notion that the mother of
God is this throne right it is the one
who holds this infant in her arms but
now we also have her showing us saying
this is where you need to look right I'm
here to point towards the ultimate
mystery which is Christ and so that also
becomes an image of what we're we're
supposed to do as the church itself
we're supposed to point towards Christ
and so yoga tria becomes the first you
will see all these types of images of
the mother with the child this kind of
sitting with the child in her hand on
their side and and this is the origin of
all those images even now we have these
very kind of cute images of the baby on
the hunt on the mother's breasts are
falling asleep all these types of images
but the source of that tradition all
comes from this icon which is she who
shows the way yeah she intended to look
sign here is this is what the modern I
see is this well I mean I think
definitely it's it's partly the way that
the modernize is the style but there is
in an iconography that say modern
interpreters they talk about this joyful
sadness and so this notion that there is
a sober sadness in
in iconography but also a joy which is
hidden in that but it's not it's not
this kind of exuberance or whatever but
it whatever there is a kind of sober
sadness also because we also have to
always remember that that she that she
lived with the knowledge of her son's
death like she she that she lived with
that band and so we can show that in the
image even though how I see some props
you know it's not that she was probably
always thinking about that but when we
make an icon we're kind of pulling all
these things together to create a
meaningful image so we can show you can
show that in here and often in the the
older versions of the area of the the
one she who shows the way you'll notice
that her head is slightly tilted her
head is is tilted down towards Christ
and she's actually she's bowing to
Christ okay
she's actually you know she's holding
her child but she's also now and took
her child and so we'll see how that that
type of structure of she who shows the
way moves into another type of image
which is called the dances I'll show
that to you now okay so so the the the
Babli is really also one of the basic
one of the basic images of Christian art
and what it usually is
it's Christ now not as a child now not
as this infant but Christ and glory
it's the Christ who returns at the end
of time and so he is standing in the
center and and to his right most of the
time to his right is Mary and then to
his left can be I'm sorry so he bring
the gods water yes and then to to his
left will be often st. John the Baptist
or it can also be st. John the
as well and so this image now we still
have the two angels there above did you
see them up there this is really it that
the important thing because it it
signifies this presence this this
presence of God and so this image hoping
you'll see it becomes a very very
central image in in in iconography this
is a much later yeah it's a Greek icon
so much later Greek icon would you see
it has this same pattern
Christ is sitting on his throne but now
it's really the the the throne of
judgment this throne of the end of times
and standing next to him our is our the
mother of God and Saint John who are
what are they doing look at their hands
right they're doing two things actually
on the one hand they're pointing they're
showing they're saying this is this is
him right this is we're all turned
towards this image we're all turned
towards Christ and at the same time
they're also praying they're bowing
they're bowing before their Lord and
they're also praying and they're they
become they become the image of all of
us who are praying they are praying for
us right they're praying for all of us
and then they also become the image of
how we're all praying for each other
we're all praying for each other we're
all they're looking towards Christ
looking through the mother of God
through Saint John looking towards
Christ and all praying for each other
and and moving towards that ultimate
glorious image and so that this this
this image of I wanted to show you just
one image of the mother and child then
in as time continues then the image of
the mother and child becomes more
relational if you look at that code
against we have the first image it's
really more about really more about her
presenting her child to us okay whereas
the image the the Virgin of lat
and then a lot of other images that
you've all seen of Mary and holding her
child is it becomes a little bit more
about this relationship between the son
and her child but in this image in
particular it's very important to notice
that she is looking at us and she still
has her hand up she's still showing the
way she's still showing us her child and
now the child is showing his affection
towards his mother right and we have to
we have to be able to always understand
that in terms of our of our life in
terms of what it means for us in terms
of how this idea of what let's say she
is there to bring us in to him and he is
showing his affection for her for his
church for his mother for that which
manifests him he is showing that
relationship of love to the two to his
to his body really all right is
everybody gonna follow that does that
make sense them I hope I hope it does
enough but I'm not losing people
completely now I've showed you mostly
this image of this notion of the center
and so you have this notion of Christ as
this Center the seed right this purl
attended in the field and then the
mother of God becomes the field itself
you know we they're all these images for
example of the Rising Sun so the Christ
is the Rising Sun and the dawn is the
mother of God you'll find all of these
types of images of something which comes
as as this light or this dot or this
precious thing this treasure or whatever
and
whatever contains it becomes an image of
the Holy Mother so that's really this
notion of the center of Christ who is
hiding in the heart
who's this invisible spark you know this
invisible image that is in all of us but
that we can that we can come to see and
we can come to encounter if we see
things in the right way but then there's
another way of seeing it which is really
now going back going back back back to
the very first images of Genesis which
is this first first relationship between
heaven and earth between the spiritual
and we could say the material and now
we'll see a whole bunch of images which
will then we present this idea of heaven
and earth and and show them to us in the
in the image of the church and the
Christian story so this is a sixth
century image this is a very early image
we don't have a lot of for those who
don't know there's a whole bunch of
images that we don't have for several
centuries because there was a fight in
the church on images and so a lot of
images were destroyed and so when we say
you have a sixth century image of that
in a book it's quite astounding and so
this is a can anybody guess what this is
an image of yeah yeah it's the Ascension
okay so it's an image of the Ascension
of Christ okay so what I've already told
you a little bit about about certain
structures are there something you can
notice in this image if you look down
you'll see the mother of God what will
necessarily be next to her threat to
angels okay and the angels are there in
the text but the mother of God is
actually not
in the text she's not in she's not
mentioned as being there at the
Ascension but the importance of showing
her at the Ascension becomes this
relationship now between heaven and
earth and so you have this line which
cuts across the icon then you have the
heavenly world and now you have the
earthly world and Mary becomes this
central point becomes the arc again
becomes the the throne on the earth
representing the earth around her is the
church and its really the church and
that's that's super important to
understand it's not just a
representation of what happened and how
do we tell it's not just a
representation of what happened look at
the image some of you might be able to
tell me why we know well first off Mary
isn't mentioned in the text it's
possible she was there
there is someone in that image which
there's no way was there and that st.
Paul okay so st. Paul is traditionally
represented at the Ascension why because
it's not just an image of the moment of
something that happened in history it's
an image of it's a pattern which
represents the very structure of the
church ultimately I would say the very
structure of reality itself not even
just the church this is how the world
works
this image shows you how the world works
okay and so you have you have the head
of the church right Christ is the head
of the church Christ has ascended into
heaven and he is up there in in the
heavens and then below is the body and
so the mother of God becomes the central
focus becomes the ultimate image of the
body she is the one who gave body to the
logos and so she becomes the altar
image of the body the throne and next to
her of course those angels that help you
to remember the Ark of the Covenant and
then finally the church itself which
surrounds this whole event which me
which flows out of this event okay
and so st. Peter is on sin Peter is here
and see him he's got the keys can you
see right and then st. Paul is here and
then all of the other apostles like
here's a here's a more modern a more
modern version I'm showing you this just
so you can see this is this is
definitely based on on that tight it's
not even though it's modern it looks
like something which could have been
painted a thousand years ago I assure
you and so here we really get this
relationship okay
Christ ascending into heaven he's
sitting on a rainbow okay
he's sitting on a dome right this this
this rainbow which is both an image of
heaven itself as this dome but also an
image of a bridge between heaven and
earth he is he is above everything and
the mother of God there in the center
and looking what she is she's standing
on can you see that and that is a
footstool and so she's standing on a
footstool why is she standing on a
footstool huh because in the in the
Psalms it says that it says that God his
throne is in heaven and his foot his
footstool is the earth so his throne is
heaven and his footstool is the earth
and so the mother of God becomes not
just an image even of the church itself
but of all of creation of how all of
creation has the possibility in it it
can possibly manifest God you know not
that it always does but that then it is
possible and
that's let's say the mystery of the
church is that creation itself that that
the things we make that the this
building that these people gathering you
know that this water that this wine that
this bread that this oil all of these
can become you know can become vehicles
in which we can encounter in which we
can come into contact with the divine
and so this is a this is a this is the
dome at st. Mark's in Venice and it's an
image of the Ascension okay so once
again you can probably now start to
recognize what's going on in there in
the center of the dome is the ascending
Christ below him there she is now as the
mother of God with the two angels can
you see who's standing next to the
angels so who are these guys
Franks and Peter and st. Paul right and
then the other apostles are are around
it now what's important to understand is
that the image of Christ in the dome
which became which became more prominent
in the east I have to admit but this
image of Christ in the dome becomes an
image of Christ that is returning and
it's the returning Christ and here we
see that it's also the Christ that is
ascending if you look at this that image
of there of Christ that's how we
represent Christ at the Last Judgement
that's how we represent Christ who is
who is returning but it's also all who
represent Christ and she is ascending
now I mean there's a there's a reason a
technical reason for that because when
the Angels the angel spoke to the
disciples they told them that just as he
said
so - he will return but what's important
to understand is mostly this
relationship that if you freeze this
image it becomes an image of the church
itself the content income becomes an
image of the manner in which we gather
together into into the church in order
to look up towards towards the reigning
Christ
yeah and we'll see that we'll see that
when we get to the image of the the debt
the Dormition of the mother of god we
see the disciples sensing incensing
around her and everything really is the
sense of the liturgy I think it's gonna
get too dark on that still you still get
ok oh yeah ok so then in order to help
you kind of see what I'm talking about
in terms of this relationship now I'm
talking mostly about the Eastern Church
because that's what I know but in the
Eastern Church what ended up happening
is that in the in the apse okay so you
all know what the absence the apse is
the easternmost part of the church where
the altar is so traditionally the apse
would have been a semicircular don't
like a Half Dome and you can see it if
you look at all cathedrals to look at
old churches you will see that at the
end eastern end of the church is this
Half Dome and now in the Half Dome
we represent the mother of God with the
to the Christ child okay show you
several several examples of that
now in the dome right the full dog which
is above the churches in the center of
the church which is the heaven itself a
representation of heaven itself then we
represent Christ in the form of what we
saw as the ascending Christ but also the
returning Christ and as Christ has the
head of the church Christ as the King of
Kings you know the the highest
representation of the health of the of
the human and the divine in heaven and
then at the lower level at the level
that say you have imagine you have a
dome like that right and then underneath
there and then you have a lower tier in
which the church would be and the apps
will be at that level and so you have
the same relationship in the church
right the same relationship as in the
ascension the architecture of the church
itself represents the same thing have
Christ up in the dome and then now at
the lower tier where we are we are you
have a mother of God as the ultimate
aspect but also because in the east
there's also this whole idea that here
is the dawn like here is the horizon and
out of the horizon comes the Rising Sun
and so the mother God is that horizon
and the child the Christ child comes out
so you can see the Christ child here
kind of hidden in the church and finally
you also have this manifestation of the
totality of the of the ascending and
returning Christ up in the dome all
right okay so another form another form
of the Babli which is related also to
what we're talking about is the
crucifixion right the crucifixion is
also related I mean there there are
other aspects to the images I'm telling
you but I'm trying to help you thread a
line through them so that you can see
how how this is all these are can be
related and the crucifixion also is is
related to this notion of the mother of
God as being this image of the mother of
all of us as the mother of the church
because the most simple versions of the
crucifixion unless it's just Christ
alone on the cross but usually the next
tier is this image so it's Christ and
then the mother of God on his right and
then st. John on his left so why are we
representing that scene does anybody
remember what Christ says when this is
happening so he's saying this this is
your son and then I was telling to John
his beloved disciple this is your mother
and of course this is they're not just
it's not just there to show us some
little kid bit of a story that happened
or if we emphasize that because it's
meaningful to all of us because it
becomes the pattern another pattern of
the church itself another pattern by
which she is our mother and she is as we
are in Christ she becomes an image of
our mother all of us and then me if we
are the beloved disciples obviously that
helps that you want to show two images
the God this is a copy version but I
mean this image we've seen you know you
can see it today if you go to a
graveyard you will be able to see often
you'll be able to see that image it's
such a prominent image in Christianity
it's it's it's continuing today in all
all the traditions and so finally we
come now to the two today the oldest
images of our feast today is an image
that's called the Dormition or the
falling asleep of the mother
and so you can see again
it's the same structure but can you see
that it's the same structure you see
that Christ is there above okay
now the mother of God is laying down and
who's next to her
who's that can use knows to say Paul at
st. Peter right and then the other
disciples are usually less less
recognizable but it's the same and
usually here it will show here st. Peter
is holding a sensor right and he's
sensing the body and Christ is holding
in his hands a baby so who is the baby
it's Mary
now this is the flip right this isn't
this is the flip this is the you know we
talk about the resurrection but we don't
know what we're talking about right and
so there are ways that the church tries
to show us the resurrection because we
don't know what that is I don't know
what the resurrection is there there
there are hints there are images that
the church uses in different ways and so
this image is a manner is a way to help
us see this strange change that happens
just as the mother of God was shown to
contain in side her to have this child
you know in her womb holding this child
and and being like the throne for her
child
now the tables turn and Christ is
holding the soul of this infant Mary in
his arms well is that because
hold on we have to be like the HR to go
to Jesus poop like the Charlie's God I
mean it's probably part of it it's
probably part of but I think it's
they're definitely also too to relate to
the other image and I'll explain to you
why because in like for example in an
Orthodox Church that image in the apse
right I totally the image of the ass
would be would be married holding the
Christ child in his hands and the image
of the Dormition this image of the death
of of the mother of God will be on the
western wall so if you stood in the
middle of the church and you look east
you would see the mother of God holding
Christ in her arms and if you looked
West you would see Christ he'll think
the mother of God in his arms and so
there's this there's this kind of flip
that happens where you know it turns out
that ultimately we will we are in Christ
like we ultimately we are in Christ but
it's an expression in the Christian code
that death for us is a birth in time
yeah of course yeah that's another way
to see it but notice now here also you
can see the two angels right the two
meals are always have to be there but in
in in the in the Western tradition then
there develop this other way of
representing this mystery right of
representing the mystery and it came to
be known as the as the Assumption so
here here here are the first images of
the Assumption in the very first images
of the Assumption they would always show
the Dormition at the bottom right do you
have this image of of the of the
Dormition here the mother god falling
asleep and then they would show yes the
[ __ ] above it okay so it was this D
hearing here he's holding still holding
that that that image of the man of God
in his arms but now there's also this
notion of ascending and I think I think
that that's really I think it's just
really two ways of showing this mystery
but of showing this mystery of how how
we are how she came to be united with
God and how she is the promised by the
hope of all of us right that's that's
what that's what Mary is right she's
she's the hope that we can to the extent
that it's possible you know there Christ
in us and then then also be united to
Christ in ultimately in totality and
then finally the image one of the images
that kind of finish off the whole cycle
is the final image of the crowning of
Mary so now this this this woman who
held the secret logos the secret
Emmanuel in her womb in her arms now she
has ascended and becomes the Queen you
know it becomes the co-regent with
Christ and that's really I mean it's
really it's really a call for what for
what the church is meant to be in the
world the church and the Christians
themselves like that's what we're where
we are called to be that's why we have
even now we have patron saints wine we
have patron saints because we are called
to Co rule with Christ those who who are
able to pet you know to attain to a
certain level of holiness then become
patrons they become Co rulers with
Christ and the first image of that the
ultimate image of that is of course Mary
herself because she's the she's the host
she's the one who had an inside
and she becomes the church itself like
the image of the church itself so when
we see an image of the crowning of Mary
it's it's an image of the crowning of of
the Resurrection itself right it's an
image of the of the crowning of the
church itself in the Indy it's uh but
it's it's uh how can I say this we can
only see it eschatologically we can only
see it
dimly let's say until the final things
are reveal but all these images are
there to help us understand you know
what it is we're part of so it's also an
image of creation perfected to the new
Adam knew Eve I think to know back to
the garden yeah I think so and I think I
think it goes further than that I mean
it's it's hard to talk about these
things because because you know because
it's time to talk about this thing
because because if people get freaked
out of the imagery but it's this is
really an image of Mary has the bride
right she's no longer her his mother but
she's becoming his bride not if you
don't have to think about in terms of
moral and moral sense but like just as
we are also called to be the church
itself is called to be the light of
Christ there are plenty of of references
in the middle ages of them of God as
being the bride as being the beloved in
the song of songs all these things don't
you don't have to be scandalized by that
type of imagery because it's not is
there to help us understand what is our
ultimate calling is to is to be that
bride and to join perfectly with the
with the logos yep after the Ascension
of Christ is no longer God incarnate per
se
he's in heaven now is that the
assumption of Mary and can also
represent the material joining Kevin
versus the meanings raining earth that
the Christ represented material is now
joining Kevin yes but you have to
understand that those two things
ultimately are the same right they're
the same that the Incarnation that
everything everything was accomplished
at the cross I kind of say that like
everything was accomplished at the cross
the Incarnation in the Incarnation we
find the totality of the whole cosmic
story you know even though there's
there's this eschatological notion but
that that in the Incarnation that's
already implies it's all it's all
implied the fact that we are called to
as the body you know let's say move into
God and be then be taken in to God you
know say st. Irenaeus said right that
that Christ that God we can't was that I
think it now saying that tenacious who
phrase it that way but he said that God
became man so that man could become God
right and those two things happen at the
same time it's not like what happens and
then the other that's the joining of
heaven and earth so does anybody I think
we've gone to the end like this is the
end of the world questions after the end
of the world you are very free to ask
them yeah
a line of questioning and then we can
riff on excel know if it has a single
answer but it seems that the mother of
god is distinguished as not she's not
God but she seems to be like the closest
that which is not God can be to God yeah
and then her pearls story seems to be
the bringing or the relationship of what
is not God like like he said like
there's the Sun and then there's that
which the Sun happens in which is the
dawn the dawn is up the Sun but without
a dawn there would be no relationship to
the size so so that container that which
that which God touches is still not God
but then there's this transformation of
that which is not gone into of pure
relationship with God okay okay I repeat
that question all right so so Benjamin
is asking about how it seems to him that
that mary is that which is not Guf right
and so God comes down and joins himself
to that which is not God and in which is
the closest she could be the closer to
what is not God to God and so it shows
us how is that my getting what you're
saying is that is that okay well I I am
I'm Orthodox and so in I'm in indoors in
our tradition we do have what's what's
called theosis it's not a it's not it's
not pretend like there really is this
idea that the ultimate purpose of
creation is to be deified right is to
become God by participation and so and
so that's I think you know in in the in
the Eastern tradition when we talk about
the Dormition of Mary who say that's her
theosis that is her becoming God to the
extent that it's possible by
participation we don't become God by
nature but we can
participate in God you know to the
extent that we are completely
transparent and full and so the notion
of the the manner in which creation is
participating in God you have to
understand it you have to always
understand it eschatologically you
always have to understand it as this
this totality and so the the idea of
that let's say that Mary is not God
that's that's absolutely true but she is
called like we're all called to become
God to the extent that that's possible I
keep saying that because it obviously we
don't become uncreated we're still
created but we can become completely
completely transparent and luminous and
full and become and become
principalities like we've talked about
that is that this idea why do we have
this patron saints is become that they
are ruling with Christ but we're called
to rule with Christ over the world it's
in Peter I think that's kind of the
process difficulty around it but the end
results and gradual
right well yeah because we are all
called to be Saints yeah right a lot of
these things I mean we all do our best
through prayer through following our
path that that was given to us to become
a saint to to end up in heaven wasn't
the Jesus that that's I said I think you
can see the whole story you can see this
whole story
in the image of the of the Ascension
you can see the whole story from the
beginning right right from the beginning
there is this idea that the purpose the
whole purpose right is to join heaven
and earth right that's the purpose of
creation so God creates creates you know
who pulls the the land out of the seeds
you know creates these animals create
these things but but man he pulls in all
the dust into one place and then he
blows his spirit into men so what is
that that's exactly heaven wind earth
whatever image you want to use spirit
joining itself with the earth okay so
that's that's the purpose of of creation
that's a purpose that's why God created
the world and the Incarnation becomes
the the the fulfillment of that and the
church becomes the cosmic fulfillment of
that of that Union and so that's the
purpose of the world is do to go from
this right to go from this - right -
whoops sorry
to the end to go for this to this that's
the purpose of creation all right are
there any more questions I will thank
you so much I know some of you maybe
have never never heard some of my talks
it's like maybe I was taking you on to
another planet it's possible I'm sorry
okay so I hope you appreciated I hope
you appreciated the talk thank you very
much
so I hope you enjoyed my discussion of
feminine symbolism in Christian
iconography as you can see I am NOT in
my usual place I'm actually covered in
marble dust and I'm working on a very
big marble monument right now maybe some
of you have noticed that I've been less
active on social media in the last let's
say a few weeks and that would be the
reason why there are there are a lot of
things going on these days and so as
some of you who haven't follow me online
my website is finally finished you can
find it at WWE symbolic worldcom and
there you will get all the every single
video that I put up every podcast is up
there and it's just the beginning
hopefully soon we'll have merchandise
probably also transcripts and maybe even
some writing that is specifically for
the website and the reading list that so
many of you have asking for I finally
put it up it is a summary reading list
obviously I try to not make it too too
long just a few books of the people I
think are worth reading and so hopefully
you'll find some food for thought in
that the website was made by anomalous
design they did a really good job at
designing it with me putting it all
together putting all the blog posts up
so you know so I'll put a link to their
company in the description you can check
them out if you need some work done also
thanks to all your generous patreon
support all probably working with
anomalous to keep the website up put all
the latest information up the latest
events and everything so thanks again
everybody for supporting me in the last
month of October I had two events in
Toronto we were four Wickliffe college
at the University of Toronto I'm going
to be putting those up very soon and in
November I've got three events in
Montreal so those of you were in
Montreal you can check out now you can
check out the website and you will find
the dates of those events and the
location and everything you need to know
so there's a lot of things going on
things are still trying to increase you
know our last our recent video on
symbolism and propaganda
like 150,000 views and we've got 10,000
more subscribers so it's pretty exciting
to see things continue on this line and
if you like what you're doing please
support me on patreon there's a lot of
things I still want to do more video
editing more content for the website as
the website starts to take shape and
there's so many things going on I'm also
as I told you before working on a
graphic novel with an artist and you
will hear more about that very soon so
keep watching the videos then my next
video
let's say culture interpretation is
going to be on the symbolism of aliens
so I think you might enjoy that so see
you soon